[Music]
we are playing in a tournament like this
one what kind of wind pleases you the
most the wind pleases me the most when
it's completely undeserved but when your
opponent is out playing you all the game
ends on he blunders it's the birth twins
I like delivering a mate I like
attacking my opponent sacrificing
something and then just seeing the
hopelessness in his eyes
no when when makes me very happy when
I'm done I always find fault with my
play
we both perform well and then I just
played us right I just play slightly
better you know I hope not open it for
me
usually it has to do with the quality of
my play like if I feel like played a
good game then it brings more joy you
know very proper game so like from start
to finish where you actually created
something nothing and you know step by
step include gradually and left show
opponents thinking what did I do wrong
so when you were fast and minuter and go
relax and preparing for next game just
hope to every game that is better to win
oh very fast and metal game the like
really long fights which are kind of
back and forth and it feels like both
players are giving their all and playing
pretty well they might not be ideal
games or might not be perfect games
there might be mistakes but but those
feel like you know those big fights and
you come out on top those feel really
good what kind of loss hurts the most
losing is losing is helpful the one I
play very badly
well definitely when you lose a winning
position or because of time or because
of some but blunder that's really like
annoying playing a terrible game is
actually worse than losing itself so
like if you play terrible and don't win
at the end like even
if you manage to make a draw you still
feel bad about your play you still feel
bad about what you did I hate to lose
after a long game for example it's much
better to see in a fast game than to
play seven hours and then to lose it's
kind of stupid that's why I don't like
classical games so much that you can
place our own hours you can try your
best button them to lose it's important
I would say all losses are pretty pretty
horrible but mmm I guess the worst would
be one where let's say very avoidable
mistake in a not so tense or even tense
situation that's the ones that annoy me
the most if my opponent plays extremely
well I still hate it but I I can accept
it if I do something really stupid if I
don't play the way that I know that I
can yeah that embarrass me bothers me to
lose the most annoying way to lose is
when you're defending a slightly worse
position and then you're struggling
you're struggling you're almost there
you made it but actually not really so
that's the most annoying because if you
lose a quick game and you know you've
been crushed a place there is you didn't
really have a hope to survive well if
you're being tortured you know you feel
like this fish that is on the hook and
it's always moving but then eventually
you end up one on the plate